si vous demandez à rhein qassam où ils
se situent en politique il se dit
clairement à droite proche de steve
banane ancien directeur de campagne de
donald trump
il a aussi travaillé en faveur du bric
site avec nigel farrage le leader
indépendantiste britannique ian kington
il a fondé ce site d'information très
conservateur suspendu plusieurs fois par
twitter pour certaines publications
il a été l'un des premiers à devenir
membre de parole en six mois il est
passé de 5000 à 90 milles abonnés est
une application semblable à twitter qui
fait le plein d'usagers qui se disent à
droite de l'échiquier politique
pas de comptes multiples possibles ni de
comptes automatisé comme des bottes
informatique
il faut donner son numéro de téléphone
c'est une plateforme neutre sans censure
dit son fondateur
si jusqu'ici sauf en cas de nudité
pornographie menaces et violences tout
ce qui se dit et plus ou moins
surveillés par des modérateurs bénévoles
et les propos haineux passe au travers
d'un filtre décidément très minces des
élus républicains comme ted clowns ont
été les premiers à s'abonner à des
personnalités de droite ou d'extrême
droite banni par les autres réseaux
sociaux pour des propos extrémistes ont
aussi été séduite par cette liberté de
parole mais qu'est ce qui a propulsé
récemment la popularité de parler après
c'est notamment lorsque twitter à
étiqueter certains tweets de donald
trump de trompeurs ou d'apologie de la
violence
le succès de par leur est manifeste mais
cela reste relatif à un coup de pouce
pourrait venir du président lui même
s'il quittait twitter
par leurs rimes qassam lui se réjouit de
voir qu'il n'ya pas que des
conservateurs américains britanniques ou
canadiens d'autres dissidents dans
certains pays comme l'arabie saoudite ou
la chine dit il qui se battent pour leur
liberté d'expression se joignent aussi à
part leur sang instance de contrôle
indépendante les réseaux sociaux comme
facebook et twitter imposent leur propre
système et sans vrai gars de fouet au
gré de sa croissance par leur pourrait
bien devoir réviser son absence de
censure face aux groupes extrémistes
comme ce fut le cas dit aaron trois
semaines pour les autres médias sociaux
plus populaire mais son pdg croit en son
modèle
en attendant par leur fait parler d'elle
et à temps de profiter de la manne de
publicité électorale d'ici la
présidentielle
nul doute que l'équipe de trump lui
ouvrira ses coffres ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada washington